we've had so many people from what I
sometimes derisively called cubicle and
and that's not fair but you know not
people working in the arts not people
working in the sciences specifically
people the you know the vast majority of
white-collar workers out there in
America who are saying it's not
mandatory yet but what do I do when it
becomes mandatory the training what what
what what should i what can I do and so
one of the most the most remarkable
communicates I got this week was from a
professional she so she authorized me to
share this i'm anonymizing her slightly
here she's a professional woman in her
30s who works in the Department of Human
Services in Minneapolis which of course
is we all know is the city at the
epicenter of current protests and riots
she is a long-term resident she loves
she loves Minneapolis so deeply and
cannot believe what she is what she is
seeing there I'm not actually going to
read the part of her letter that talks
about what she's seen in the riots and I
could I suppose I could come back to it
but just these two paragraphs with
regard to what she what she wrote to me
and like I said she told me she actually
she told me I could share this but only
if I spiff I said I was not gonna say
what city she was in to help anonymize
her and she said no please say that I'm
from Minneapolis because I want people
to understand that what they're seeing
in the videos is not what my city is and
I I just felt that so strongly because I
felt we both felt that so strongly with
regard to evergreen that is not the best
of what evergreen was that's not the but
that's not what it could do it was
allowed to be taken over as this letter
writer says my city has been allowed to
be taken up it was a small quadrant that
became the college almost instantly yeah
exactly so this is a professional woman
in her 30s who writes in part after
George Floyd's death over the last month
I have received a blitzkrieg of
communications from my union leadership
and various equity committees about the
structural changes they wish to force on
our union in our programs and on the
agency as a whole the communications
which I've attached this message are
riddled in buzz words from
raise theory and includes instructions
for white people in particular to do the
anti-racism work my job is not now in
immediate jeopardy so far everything has
remained voluntary but our Commissioner
has informed us the agency will require
anti-racism training in the future and
possible restructuring of programs this
makes me very nervous I fear that if
this ideology takes hold that will
destroy the agency I also worry that my
job might be on the line in the future
if I refuse to do the training or speak
out publicly against it
I've spoken to one employee who's also a
good friend about my fears and he seems
to think that everything will be fine
because of things scared of hand people
will speak out against it when the time
comes I'm not so optimistic so I do have
one more paragraph to read but that just
gives me chills reading it aloud people
will speak out against having faith in
the idea that people will speak out
against it when the time comes
misunderstands that you won't know when
the time has come what this author is
saying is I think the time has come and
I don't know what to do and that's
that's what we're hearing from people
and I would say one thing and I did
respond to her at some length but one
thing I would add to what I responded
with was if you have a friend who can
sees who can see this as you can and
they think that people will start
speaking up later that they won't and
you need do you need to talk to him your
friend this this will be one of the
easier conversations because he can
already see it and say why do we think
the people will start speaking up later
it will only get harder to do so ah it
will only get harder to do that's the
key not only will they not know because
the time is now right this is already
out of hand if they're not speaking up
now then they've misunderstood where we
are but the problem is that this
ideology is discovering how powerful it
is and because it's discovering how
powerful it is at the point you get to
this mythological place where you're
gonna know it's gone too far its ability
to leverage against you will be that
much greater so I mean we know from
experience it doesn't happen the people
who were going to stand up did so early
yeah right I mean we have not
accumulated almost anyone in the
Evergreen community after a certain
point everybody who
their wits about them spoke up in one
way or another and then the rest have
been silent and so even the ones who
know better silent to this day yep
that's right so one more paragraph from
the same letter writer should I say
something publicly now or wait until the
mandatory training starts and refused to
take them take the training and offer
criticism quietly warn others against
this simply ignore it and hope it goes
away
I know you've offered general advice
already but speaking publicly now may
not be the best approach if I'm going to
stick my neck out I'd like it at least
to be effective do you have any advice
for what to do it but the change is
enacted by the Minneapolis City Council
should I call it a lost cause and
abandon the city I love should I buy a
gun so I told you last night as I was
reading this I said I've just received
an amazing letter and I want to read
part of it so this was your first time
hearing this as well I relate to it and
I do think we have an obligation to
speak to the question what I can't say
is that there is a good answer there are
better answers and worse answers but
there are no good answers yeah that's
exactly right man I could even I could
read part of my answer here and it's it
but it says it's as much much that
[Music]